I thought that maybe since you've taken
to interviewing people you would want to
ask Dave Attell and Ian finance a
question if you want all right I mean I
got one in mind
uh-huh I mean I know it's two days in a
row but like they say pork roll is life
of pork roll yeah
it's [ __ ] great you get an answer
from Dave all about you there in the
corner this is really how you treat a
guy you let them answer question to
other people who ones last day yeah I
mean what David it makes him happy Dave
Wow you are a legend okay here's the
thing that's like hey we're gonna take
you out to eat whatever we don't eat you
can eat what is it pork roll is one of
the best breakfast sandwiches
oh I thought it was a new kind of pot or
something do you want me to buy you one
[Laughter]
do you have a lot of friends back up at
what's the college yeah I did I like
dorm zeros out of community school I
mean there's dorms there but a lot of
people commute so what do you guys party
like what do you do it at the train
station or there you go that my way
Mahwah oh I met a cam girl that went
there yeah it's probably one of the best
cam girl schools in the country it's the
Harvard of cam girl bus what your what
your study what are you studying
I'm a social science major I have a
concentration and environmental
sustainability and what do you hope to
do with that be awkward on the radio
he's holding his own I don't what do you
think well really I I started undeclared
was taking classes didn't really know
what I wanted to do I did radio shows in
high school in college
when I found out that I wanted to pursue
broadcasting further I was like well I
don't want to start all over so I just
stuck with the classes and then I got
the internship and did outside stuff in
broadcasting she's smart
that's good Mari making the best of his
situation I like it that's resourceful
that's cool you started doing it in high
school that must have been really fun
yeah my high school had a radio station
and did that for a few years then I go
away we play music like what kind of
station was I mean in high school I
didn't have a choice I had to play
country music but it was like not a talk
show - I'm in college I did more of a
talk show and I since it was
commercial-free I played some songs in
between but not much like two or three
songs in between what's up more music
classic rock has its own radio station
[Laughter]
original high school so it was a big
high school you know I mean all right
all high school sounds more like a jail
to me did you want to ask any follow-up
questions to prove any points about you
because you started with the pork roll
the poor girl thing I don't know if
there was anyone I took a little issue
with that as a Jewish person I thought
it was leading me to something there all
I see there was a kind of a jingle of
anti-semitism - I see where you would
pick up on that mm-hmm did you intend
for that to be there Frank a happy
accident he's wearing a free Palestine
sure you've heard of poor crow before
have you ever heard it called anything
else no down at the orphanage they used
to call it Christmas
[Laughter]
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app
[Music]